[Music]
you've been with Twilight for four and a
half years and now it's done what now do
you know um not really no I don't know
yet I'm like in desperate search of a
job actually something that I really
like can't seem to make my way forth
past this little Twilight thing you know
right would you like to be an intern
here at the show we'll find you
something to do
Stuart where's my coffee it's just well
you must be getting like different kinds
of are you are you getting different
kinds of roles now like you read scripts
people send you scripts they desperately
want you to be in their movie are you
getting roles that are more out there
that are different that order departure
from what you've been doing um yeah I I
the whole girl-power thing is such a big
deal now there's like an enormous void
that has clearly been proven you know
there's a desire to fill that that's why
I like audiences made themselves very
known but it's um if you just change
like if you just change your character
name from Bobby to Sue suddenly or just
I mean any anything anything where like
a girl is punching another person in a
face or like being really assertive
suddenly they're like oh we definitely
will look at Kristen Stewart to do this
one it's like faux girl power is really
revolting so it's like they're literally
sending you old Clint Eastwood scripts
but changing the name
and you're beating the crap out of
people and then like puffing on a
cigarette I'm out of here or old Swartz
and Egger rolls
I wish it's quite shocking
no I but I just say that there it's it
seems to me that that that would be a
danger is that people just trying to
overthink it you know and get you to do
roles that do not I mean that just like
take the girl power thing but maybe take
it to an extreme stop thinking what is
the use in that just make a movie it's
all good no what are you high
stop thinking it's all good